trailers trailers a million ways to die
in the West is directed written produced
starred everything by Seth MacFarlane
the creator of Family Guy in the
director of Ted I really like Ted I
thought it was a funny film I really
enjoyed the camaraderie between a teddy
bear and Mark Wahlberg which is
something I didn't think I'd ever say
ever this movie has a very similar
structure to it except it takes place in
the Old West it's not as much of a buddy
tale but it has the same sort of skit to
skit feel Seth MacFarlane plays a really
good hearted kind guy and he just wants
to find someone who cares about him as
much as he cares about them and when he
meets Charlize Theron he has that
opportunity but he has to also try to
win back his former love played by
Amanda Seyfried who is now with Neil
Patrick Harris who has an incredible
mustache which is apparently what he is
most soon for in this movie now as I
hinted in my intro the trailers really
gave away a lot of the best parts of
this movie some of the funniest jokes
were unfortunately in the trailers and
just in case you have not seen the
trailer I won't spoil for you the
incredible cameo that is in this movie
that would have been so great if I
hadn't have seen it on my phone while I
was sitting on a chair in my room
nowadays it's like we see everything on
our computer screens or our phone before
we see the movie and this film just gave
away way too much in the trailers
because some of the best jokes were
unfortunately in those previews and a
lot of it as I said does feel like an
elaborate string of Saturday Night Live
skits where they surround a scene around
a certain gag and it either works or it
doesn't and a lot of the jokes do miss
because I walked in this movie hoping to
laugh but some of it does kind of come
off as Seth MacFarlane's attempts to
make himself look better because he gave
himself the most sympathetic loving
caring loser role that he could have
possibly given himself because I know he
gets a lot of flack for being like a
huge dick with his comedy and when he
did the Oscars he got so much hate for
all of his misogynistic comments I
thought I did a good job at the Oscars
he's a funny guy I've liked a lot of his
stuff before as I said I like Ted and
some of the Family Guy episodes when
they first started were really great but
this movie didn't really
me laughs all that much which is kind of
the biggest crime you can commit in a
comedy because I go into a comedy all I
want to do is laugh and have it be
clever with some sophomoric stuff mixed
in there and a lot of this just felt
sophomoric and just like I talked about
in my review for the other woman we have
another movie in which a character is
given a laxative and he has to poop a
lot how many times our comedies gonna
use that exact same old joke it's not
funny anymore it just felt so incredibly
confident with its material which
sometimes is a good thing but when your
material is kind of a it's a bad thing
this movie definitely comes off as Seth
MacFarlane's attempt to make his own
Blazing Saddles old western satire type
thing except the satire elements of the
film don't feel smart
they just feel like hey here's a current
in joke or I'm going to say Mila Kunis
his name would make it sound like I'm
speaking a different language but I'm
actually just going Mila Kunis and I
don't find that funny it's just like hey
by the way Mila Kunis did a voice on
that show that I created and she was in
Ted I know her I'm gonna say her name in
this movie and the story with Liam
Neeson hunting after Charlize Theron
just felt very forced because there are
attempts in this movie to go for a more
action and realistic sense and it just
copied straight out of Indiana Jones in
the Last Crusade this horse chase to a
train and then all of a sudden he just
magically somehow teleports into a
moving train with his horse and I just
was like okay I was supposed to take
that scene seriously because they set up
the action scene completely seriously
it's not a gag scene then all of a
sudden he somehow got his horse into a
moving train and so when the film did
attempt to be more serious like that I
couldn't buy and do it either Liam
Neeson is enjoyable in this film as the
main villain Charlize Theron is a fun
presence I'm negative a million ways to
die in the West se I do think it has
some funny moments most of the more
unfortunately in the trailers the film
has some good intentions and a couple
good cameos so for the most part I
didn't really find this movie very funny
and when you're watching a comedy that's
not cool guys let me know what you
thought of the film if you do see it or
if you have seen it I'm interested in
knowing what you thought and as always
thank you so much for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
it's demonised